Prince Harry Meghan Markle and Megan's
mother Doria Ragland were involved in a
near catastrophic car chase with highly
aggressive Paparazzi Tuesday night E.T
can confirm
in a statement to ET on Wednesday a
spokesperson for the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex explains that the chase lasted
over two hours and resulted in multiple
near collisions with other drivers
pedestrians and two New York Police
Department officers
while being a public figure comes with a
level of interest from the public it
should never come at the cost of
anyone's safety there's a lot of people
who think they've got such a problem
with with Paparazzi back in my mum's day
is it was physical harassment you know
cameras in your face
following you chasing you
et has learned the chase involved half a
dozen blacked out Vehicles the drivers
were confronted by uniformed police
multiple times but sped off in continued
pursuit of Harry and Megan
among the traffic violations committed
driving on the sidewalk Running Red
Lights reversing down a one-way Street
driving while photographing and
illegally blocking a moving vehicle the
NYPD tells ET in a statement they
assisted the private security team
protecting Harry and Megan after
numerous photographers made their
transport challenging they add the Duke
and Duchess arrived at their destination
and there were no reports of injuries
collisions or arrests in regard
meanwhile a New York photographer who
was part of the paparazzi following the
couple tells ET that it was actually
Harry and Megan's driver who said the
tone claiming they were running red
lights driving the wrong way on a
one-way Street and turning right on reds
which is not legal in NYC as for rumors
Megan and Harry had a film crew with
them their rep shuts it down telling ET
it's not true quote I can guarantee you
that the photog's Recollections are
absolutely false of course this Chase
feels all too familiar Harry's mom
Princess Diana died in 1997 after a car
crash involving Paparazzi in Paris
Prince Harry has always had an issue
with the media I think it's fair to say
he hates the paparazzi understandably so
he blames them for his mother's death he
believed that they hounded her to her
deaths so you can completely understand
his um his paranoia about them about
wanting to protect Megan his family
Archie from the paparazzi Tuesday's
incident occurred after Megan was
honored by Gloria Steinem at the Miss
Foundation women of vision Awards in the
Big Apple you can Charter a path in
which what you repeat
in your daily acts of service in
kindness in advocacy in Grace and In
fairness
that those become the very things that
are recognized by the next wave of women
Megan attended the event with her mom
and husband by her side entering and
exiting the venue publicly where
Paparazzi were able to take photos
the trio also posed together on the red
carpet